so this happy pic of me was taken in
1999 I was a senior in college and it
was right after dance practice I was
really really happy and I remember
exactly where I was about a week and a
half later I was sitting in the back of
my used minivan in a campus parking lot
when I decided that I was going to
commit suicide and I went from deciding
to a full-blown planning very quickly
and I came this close to the edge of the
precipice it's the closest I've ever
come and the only reason I took my
finger off the trigger was thanks to a
few lucky coincidences and after the
fact that's what scared me the most the
element of chance so I became very
methodical about testing different ways
that I could manage my ups and downs
which has proven to be a good investment
many normal people might have say six to
ten major depressive episodes in their
lives I have bipolar depression runs in
my family I've had 50 plus at this point
and I've learned a lot I've had a lot of
at-bats many rounds in the ring with
darkness taking good notes so I thought
rather than get up and give any type of
recipe for success or highlight-reel I
would share my recipe for avoiding
self-destruction and certainly self
paralysis and the tool I found which is
proven to be the most reliable safety
net for emotional freefall is actually
the same tool that has helped me to make
my best business decisions but it's that
is secondary and it is stoicism that
sounds boring you might think of Spock
or might conjure an image like this
a cow standing in the rain it's not sad
it's not particularly happy it's just an
impassive creature taking wet of her
life sends its way you might not think
of the ultimate competitor say Bill
Belichick head coach in the New England
Patriots he is the all-time NFL record
for Super Bowl titles and stoicism has
spread like wildfire in the top of the
NFL ranks as a means of mental toughness
training in the last few years you might
not think of the founding fathers Thomas
Jefferson John Adams George Washington
to name but three students of stoicism
George Washington actually had a play
about a stoic this was Quito a tragedy
performed for his troops at Valley Forge
to keep them motivated so why would
people of action focus so much on an
ancient philosophy this seems very
academic and I would encourage you to
think about stoicism a little bit
differently as an operating system for
thriving and high stress environments
for making better decisions and it all
started here kind of on a porch so
around 300 BC in Athens someone named
Zeno of City M taught many lectures
walking around a painted porch a stoah
that later became stoicism and in the
greco-roman worlds
people use stoicism as a comprehensive
system for doing many many things but
for our purposes chief among them was
training yourself to separate what you
can control from what you cannot control
and then doing exercises to focus
exclusively on the former this decreases
emotional reactivity which can be a
superpower
conversely let's say you're a
quarterback you miss a pass you get
furious with yourself that could cost
you a game if you're CEO and you fly off
the handle at a very valued employee
because of a minor infraction that could
cost you the employee if you're a
college student who say is in a downward
spiral and you feel helpless and
hopeless unabated that could cost you
your life so the stakes are very very
high and there are many tools
the toolkit to get you there I'm gonna
focus on one that completely changed my
life in 2004 and it found me then
because of two things
a very close friend young guy my age
died of pancreatic cancer unexpectedly
and then my girlfriend who I thought I
was going to marry walked out she'd had
enough and she didn't give me a Dear
John letter but she did give me this a
Dear John plaque I'm not making this up
I've kept it business hours are over at
five o'clock she gave this to me to put
on my desk for personal health because
at the time I was working on my first
real business had no idea what I was
doing I was working 14 plus hour days
seven days a week I was using stimulants
to get going I was using depressants to
wind down and go to sleep it was a
disaster felt completely trapped and I
bought a book on simplicity to try to
find answers and I did find a quote that
maybe made a big difference in my life
which was we suffer more often in
imagination than in reality
my Seneca the younger there's a famous
stoic writer that took me to his letters
which took me to the exercise
premeditate oh ma lorem which means the
premeditation of Evil's and in simple
terms this is visualizing the worst-case
scenarios in detail that you fear
preventing you from taking action so
that you can take action to overcome
that paralysis my problem was monkey
mind super loud very incessant just
thinking my way through problems doesn't
work I needed to capture my thoughts on
paper so I created a written exercise
that I called fear setting like goal
setting for myself and it consists of
three pages super simple the first page
is right here what if I dot dot dot
question mark this is whatever you fear
whatever is causing you anxiety whatever
you're putting off could be asking
someone out ending a relationship asking
for promotion quitting a job starting a
company could be anything for me it was
taking my first vacation in four years
and stepping away from my business for a
month to go to London where I could stay
in a friend's room for free
to either remove myself as a bottleneck
in the business or shut it down in the
first column define your writing down
all of the worst things you can imagine
happening if you take that step and you
want 10 to 20 I'm not going to go
through all of them but I'll give you
two examples so one was I'll go to
London
it'll be rainy I'll get depressed the
whole thing will be a huge waste of time
number two
I'll miss a letter from the IRS and I'll
get audited or raided or shut down or
somesuch
then you go to the prevent column and
that column you write down the answer to
what could I do to prevent each of these
bullets from happening or at the very
least decrease the likelihood even a
little bit so for getting depressed in
London well I could take a portable blue
light with me use it for 15 minutes in
the morning I knew that help to stave
off depressive episodes so the IRS bit I
could change the mailing address on file
at the IRS so the paperwork would go to
my accountant instead of to my UPS
address easy peasy then we go to repair
so if the worst case scenario has
happened what could you do to repair the
damage even a little bit or who could
you ask for help so in the first case
London well I could fork over some money
fly to Spain
get some Sun undo the damage if I got
into a funk in the case of missing
letter from the IRS I could call a
friend who is a lawyer or ask say a
professor of law what they would
recommend who I should talk to you how
had people handled this in the past so
one question to keep in mind as you're
doing this first page is has anyone else
in the history of time less intelligent
or less driven figured this out chances
are the answer is yes the second page is
simple what might be the benefits of an
attempt or a partial success so you can
see we're playing up the fears and
really taking a conservative look at the
upside so if you attempted whatever
you're considering might you build
confidence develop skills emotionally
financially otherwise what might be the
benefits of say a basehit spend 10 to 15
minutes on this page 3 this might be the
most important so
skip it the cost of inaction humans are
very good at considering what might go
wrong if we try something new say ask
for a raise we don't often consider is
the atrocious cost of the status quo not
changing anything so you should ask
yourself if I avoid this action or
decision and actions and decisions like
it what might my life look like in say
six months twelve months three years any
further out it starts to see him
intangible and really get detailed again
emotionally financially physically
whatever and when I did this it painted
a terrifying picture I was
self-medicating my business was going to
implode at any moment at all times
I didn't step away my relationships were
fraying or failing and I realized that
inaction was no longer an option for me
those are the three pages that's it
that's pure selling and after this I
realized that on a scale of one to ten
one being minimal impact 10 being
maximal impact if I took the trip I was
risking a 1 to 3 of temporary and
reversible pain for an 8 to 10 of
positive life-changing impact that could
be semi-permanent so I took the trip
none of the disasters came to pass there
were some hiccups sure I was able to
extricate myself from the business I
ended up extending that trip for a year
and a half around the world and that
became the basis for my first book that
leads me here today and I can trace all
of my biggest wins and all of my biggest
disasters averted back to doing fear
setting at least once a quarter it's not
a panacea you'll find that some of your
fears are very well founded
but you shouldn't conclude that without
first putting them under a microscope
and it doesn't make all the hard times
the hard choice is easy but it can make
a lot of them easier so I'd like to
close with a profile of one of my
favorite modern-day Stoics this is
Jersey Gregor Eck he is a four-time
world champion in Olympic weightlifting
political refugee published poet
sixty-two years old he can still kick my
ass and probably most asses in this room
he's an impressive guy I spend a lot of
time on his stoah his porch asking life
and training advice he was part of the
Solidarity in Poland which was a
non-violent movement for social change
that was violently suppressed by the
government he lost his career as a
firefighter then his mentor a priest was
kidnapped tortured killed and thrown
into a river
he was then threatened he and his wife
had to flee Poland bounced from country
to country until they landed in the US
with next to nothing sleeping on floors
he now lives in Woodside California in a
very nice place and of the 10,000 plus
people I've met in my life I would put
him in the top ten in terms of success
and happiness and there's a punch line
coming it's a pay attention I sent him a
text a few weeks ago asking him have you
ever read any stoic philosophy and he
replied with two pages of text this is
very unlike him he is a tourist dude and
not only was he familiar with stoicism
but he pointed out for all of his most
important decisions his inflection
points when he stood up for his
principles and ethics how he had used
stoicism and something akin to fear
setting which blew my mind
and he closed with two things number one
he couldn't imagine any life more
beautiful than that of a stoic and the
last was his mantra which he applies to
everything and you can apply to
everything easy choices hard life hard
choices easy life the hard choices what
we most fear doing asking saying these
are very often exactly what we most need
to do and the biggest challenges and
problems we face will never be solved
with comfortable conversations whether
it's in your own head or with other
people so I encourage you to ask
yourselves where in your lives right now
Mike defining your fears be more
important than defining your goals
keeping in mind all the while the
words of Seneca we suffer more often in
imagination than in reality thank you
very much
[Applause]